[Music]
are you one of those people who hate
these little crawling things or maybe
these ones with the stingers creeped you
out more have you ever wished that all
the insects would just die out picnics
would be much more pleasant and so would
gardening could the world become a
better place if insects disappeared or
would this have terrible consequences
not obvious for us at first glance this
is what if and here's what would happen
if all insects disappeared from the
planet if you think bugs only exist to
give you the creeps and to chew on the
lettuce in your garden you're wrong well
not totally wrong some of them are in
fact meant to destroy crops give you
skin irritations in addition to painful
stings and even worse spread diseases
like Zika and malaria but 90% of them
are not only harmless but beneficial to
us and to the planet they say without
insects the world would fall apart just
how bad would that be if we put all the
insects on the planet together on a
scale they would weigh approximately 300
times more than all humans combined if
you haven't sect a phobia you probably
want me to stop right here just let me
add that the ants alone would weigh more
than all humans if our planet suddenly
had all this weight off its shoulders
farmers would be the first to celebrate
they'd no longer need to pour chemicals
on their crops to save the harvest from
hungry pests but that celebration
wouldn't last long because without
insects we'd all starve pretty fast and
no we don't mean that those bold
adventurers who snack on crickets and
grasshoppers somewhere in Thailand would
starve humans might be predators in the
food chain but insects are the ones to
hold this chain together they are food
for some reptiles small birds and frogs
if all insects vanished those animals
would cease to exist to the animals
feeding on frogs and reptiles would be
the next to die off and then the ones
further up the chain
eventually this disruption would work
its way up to humans think you could
survive by going vegan wrong again
80% of all plant life on the planet is
made up of flowering plants meaning they
require pollination to reproduce insects
are the ones who make this happen by
physically transferring pollen from a
male anther to a female stigma you can
argue the birds and bats even wind can
pollinate too but most of the work is
done by bees wasps moths butterflies and
flies without them it's game over for
most plants depending on what your food
preferences are 50 to 90% of your diet
comes from those flowering plants there
would be no fruit no vegetables no rice
and no weep this also means no food for
cows chickens most freshwater fish and
all the animals we humans eat it doesn't
matter if you're a vegetarian or a meat
lover if the insects disappeared you'd
have no chance of long-term survival
you'd be left to slowly starve on a
planet heaped up with piles of organic
waste because not only do insects feed
small animals and pollinate plants there
are also major decomposers of dead stuff
from leaves to corpses that wouldn't be
the world you'd want to live in and to
be honest not all the insects are gross
looking wouldn't you agree join us next
time on what if
[Music]
[Music]